This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Our show is all about recognizing the fascinating stories behind mundane things, and I can think of nothing more mundane than seeing a McDonald's on nearly every corner. For us today, because fast food is so readily available, we often market as something that is unspecial. That's Marcia Chatlin, she's the author of a book, Franchise, The Golden Arches in Black America.
这里是99% Invisible，我是罗曼·马斯。我们的节目旨在探寻那些平凡事物背后的迷人故事，而我想象不出还有什么比在几乎每个街角看到麦当劳更平凡的事了。对今天的我们而言，由于快餐随处可见，我们常常将其视为一种平平无奇的东西。那是玛莎·查特林，她是《特许经营：黑人美国与金色拱门》一书的作者。
But for African Americans, if you consider, in the 1970s, who have only been federally protected in a public accommodation like a restaurant for maybe five, 10 years, going to McDonald's is actually a really big deal. So when I started reading Dr. Chatlin's book, I think I was expecting kind of a takedown of McDonald's, kind of like fast food nation, just the knives out, talking about all the ways that fast food companies abuse workers and animals and the planet.
但对于非裔美国人来说，如果你考虑到在20世纪70年代，他们联邦保护的公共住宿权利（比如餐馆）也才刚刚获得大概五年、十年，去麦当劳其实是一件非常了不起的大事。所以当我开始阅读查特林博士的书时，我想我大概是期待对麦当劳的某种批判，有点像《快餐帝国》那种，直接亮出底牌，痛斥快餐公司盘剥工人和动物以及地球的种种行径。
But this book is really complicated. It looks at the quote, somewhat bizarre, but incredibly powerful marriage between a fast food behemoth and the fight for civil rights. I remember when I was on my book tour, I met a woman who said she remembers going to McDonald's for the first time and getting ice cream because she had grown up in the Jim Crow South and they never went to an ice cream parlor because there was a colored only and white's only counter and her grandmother wouldn't let her go. And so they would make ice cream at home and she remembers going to get ice cream. And I think that for people who were so separated from those experiences and from the pleasure of going out and eating and enjoying themselves,
但这本书非常复杂。它探讨了快餐庞然大物与民权运动之间那种引号内“多少有些诡异，却又无比强大”的结合。我记得在做图书巡讲时，我遇到了一位女士，她说她记得自己第一次去麦当劳并吃到了冰淇淋，因为她是在吉姆·克劳法的南方长大的，他们从来没去过冰淇淋店，因为那里有黑人专柜和白人专柜，她奶奶不让她去。所以他们会在家里自己做冰淇淋，而她记得去买冰淇淋的事。所以我想，对于那些与这些经历、以及外出就餐和享受乐趣的快乐相去甚远的人们来说，
having McDonald's as a successful place and having advertisement that shows that you're welcome was a really, really big deal and it still sticks with a lot of people of that generation. My discussion with Marsha Chatlin starts in 1968 after the assassination of Dr. Martin Luther King. McDonald's joins the legions of businesses that are trying to find a way to capitalize on this urban crisis moment where there's destruction on the streets after Martin Luther King's assassination. Some white franchise owners who are doing business and predominantly black neighborhoods wanted out they were concerned about future property damage, other uprisings, and so invocating their stores, McDonald's filled those gaps with African American franchise ease, who
能有一家成功的麦当劳，能有广告显示“欢迎光临”，这是一件非常非常了不起的大事，而且至今仍留在那个时代的许多人心中。我与玛莎·查特林的对话始于1968年马丁·路德·金博士遇刺之后。麦当劳加入了一群企业的行列，试图在这个城市危机时刻寻找资本化的方法，当时马丁·路德·金遇刺后街头发生了破坏。一些在主要由黑人居住的社区做生意的白人特许经营商想要退出，他们担心未来的财产损害和其他暴动，随着他们的门店撤出，麦当劳用非裔美国人特许经营商填补了这些空白，这些人
were stepping into business for the first time. And most of us think about white flight in the context of housing and the loss of tax revenue for schools. But I think that we also have to think about economic white flight. What does it mean for white business owners to shutter their businesses, move to the suburbs and to end their main street presence? And then there were these calls for using black economic power under the umbrella of black capitalism to rebuild and reimagine black communities. Can you give me the grand unified theory of black capitalism?
是第一次涉足商业。我们大多数人在住房和学校税收流失的语境下考虑“白人群飞”。但我觉得我们也必须考虑经济上的“白人群飞”。白人企业主关闭生意、搬到郊区并结束他们在商业街的存在，这意味着什么？然后，人们呼吁在黑人资本主义的保护伞下利用黑人经济力量来重建和重新构想黑人社区。你能给我讲讲黑人资本主义的宏大统一理论吗？
Like, what is it supposed to do? What is it supposed to accomplish? So black capitalism is this idea that in the absence of full political and social rights, that if African-Americans develop a strong economic base and economic presence that this can fill the gaps and it doesn't work ever. I take I take a lot of alert folks. It does not work. And so McDonald's is there at the forefront of capitalizing on federal programs that are supposed to support Black business ownership. of capitalizing on federal programs that are supposed to support black business ownership and having this business model that they realize very quickly can actually thrive in the inner city. Right, and this is all hinged on the idea of the franchise. So could you talk about how franchising and black capitalism work together?
比如，它是用来做什么的？它应该达成什么目标？所以黑人资本主义这个想法是，在缺乏完全的政治和社会权利的情况下，如果非裔美国人建立起强大的经济基础和经济存在，这就可以填补空白，而且它从来都没用过。我得……我得给各位提个醒。它根本不管用。因此，麦当劳走在了利用旨在支持黑人企业所有权的联邦项目的前沿，并拥有了他们很快意识到实际上可以在内城蓬勃发展的商业模式。没错，这一切都取决于特许经营的概念。那么，你能谈谈特许经营和黑人资本主义是如何结合的吗？
So franchising, as I described in the book, in 40 in terms, is the idea that a parent company makes all the rules, but the children earn all the money. So the franchise model is so American because it says you don't need a fancy degree, and you don't need to have a lot of business knowledge, but you have to have the ability to be compliant, follow the rule book, pay your fees, and then you can have your own business. And so it's this idea of the easiest way to become an entrepreneur or a business owner. The reality is that franchising is predicated on you, the franchisee, assuming a lot of
所以特许经营，正如我在书中所描述的，用通俗的话来说，就是母公司制定所有规则，而子品牌赚取所有钱。所以特许经营模式非常具有美国特色，因为它表明你不需要华丽的学位，也不需要有很多商业知识，但你必须具备顺从的能力、遵守规则手册、支付费用，然后你就可以拥有自己的生意。所以这就是成为企业家或企业主的捷径的想法。现实情况是，特许经营的前提是你——特许经营商——承担了大量的
liability. For the people who are able to access these programs and the funds and the loans, they are getting to access some of the most iconic brands, some of the most established businesses, and it's supposed to be the easy way. But because of the dynamics of race and capitalism, it's never quite that easy. One of the confusing aspects of franchising is that it is unclear, or at least it's unclear me, like who actually owns the shop? Well, the initial idea of the McDonald's franchise
责任。对于能够获得这些项目、资金和贷款的人来说，他们得以接触到一些最具标志性的品牌、一些最成熟的企业，这本该是一条捷径。但由于种族和资本主义的动态关系，事情从来没有那么简单。特许经营令人困惑的一个方面是，它并不明确，或者至少对我来说并不明确，到底是谁在经营这家店？好吧，最初的麦当劳特许经营的想法
was that it was a person who owned the store and was there all the time. And so in the early days, you would know who your local franchise owner was and that person would be at the Kwanis Club. There's a person who's sponsoring Little League that this was this like very local thing. And then solely but surely in order for people to really make money in this system, they start owning multiple franchises and their portfolio is filled with fast food outlets.
是，它是一个拥有这家店并一直呆在那里的个人。所以在早期，你会知道谁是你的本地特许经营商，那个人会出现在基瓦尼斯俱乐部。会有这样一个人赞助少年棒球队，这是一件非常本地化的事情。然后为了让人们真正能在这个系统中赚钱，他们开始拥有多个特许经营权，他们的投资组合里塞满了快餐店。
But for African-Americans again, because of racial wealth gaps, they were less likely to own multiple stores. They're also likely to do business in predominantly black areas. And so when I was touring the book, some of his white audience members would say like, how long was to know who owns my franchise? That's kind of weird. And then every black person, I would say, would be like, yeah, I totally know the guy who franchises the McDonald's, because he's everywhere. He's on the radio, telling you to vote, telling you to fill your senses. He's given people jobs at the job fair. This person is such a figure and I think that that's when it gets like super murky because throughout the book people are wondering if I go to a black franchise McDonald's am I supporting a black business? And to what extent is it really a black business. And to what extent is it really a black business? It's actually really hard to answer.
但对于非裔美国人来说，由于种族财富差距，他们再次更不可能拥有多家店。他们也更倾向于在主要是黑人的地区做生意。所以当我巡回宣传这本书时，一些白人观众会说，怎么会不知道是谁拥有我的特许经营权？这有点奇怪。然后每个黑人都会说，是的，我绝对知道那个加盟麦当劳的家伙，因为他无处不在。他在收音机里，叫你去投票，叫你填写普查问卷。他在招聘会上给人提供工作。这个人简直是个风云人物，我想也就是在这个时候情况变得超级模糊，因为整本书里人们都在疑惑，如果我去一家黑人加盟的麦当劳，我是在支持一家黑人企业吗？以及它在多大程度上真的是一家黑人企业。以及它在多大程度上真的是一家黑人企业？这其实真的很难回答。
What is obvious in the exploration of your book is that black capitalism and some of the responsibilities that McDonald's would take on, whereas things that the government was failing at, could you talk a little bit about that? Because a lot of what's complicated about this relationship is not the failure of McDonald's to serve the Black community or Black business owners. It's that they're forced to serve the community and Black business owners because other structures are failing. Great. So, like, the Black business owner has historically been the unelected official of black America
在对你的书的探索中显而易见的是，黑人资本主义以及麦当劳承担的一些责任，本该是政府失职的领域，你能稍微谈谈这个吗？因为这种关系之所以复杂，很大程度上并不是因为麦当劳未能服务黑人社区或黑人企业主。而是因为其他结构正在失效，他们才被迫去服务这个社区和黑人企业主。太对了。所以，黑人企业主历史上一直是黑人美国的非民选官员，
wherever it is residing. And the franchise owner takes up that role. And initially when I thought about, how would I describe this book in one sentence, it was how McDonald's replaced the state in black America. In the sense that the McDonald's is the place where a senior citizen can hang out with friends. It is the place that is underwriting the cultural and athletic events at the local school.
无论它居于何地。而特许经营商扮演了这个角色。起初，当我考虑该如何用一句话来形容这本书时，那就是麦当劳是如何在黑人美国取代了国家的角色。从某种意义上说，麦当劳是老年人可以和朋友闲逛的地方。它是为当地学校的文化和体育活动提供赞助的地方。
It's the place where the first job training program happens, and it's the affiliation of these black franchise owners into a national organization that's allowing health screenings to happen in some places. And so, you know, a lot of the literature on black capitalism often frames it as this great failure that like in the 70s people had this wild idea that you could do these things and everything failed. But I argue that it was so successful that we don't even see its markings that we don't point to the expansion of fast food as the success of black capitalism. But that's exactly what that's part of.
它是第一个就业培训计划发生的地方，正是这些黑人特许经营商加入全国性组织，才使得某些地方能够进行健康筛查。所以，你知道，关于黑人资本主义的许多文献通常将其描述为一次巨大的失败，就像70年代人们有一个疯狂的想法，认为你可以做这些事情，结果却一切都失败了。但我认为它如此成功，以至于我们甚至看不到它的痕迹，我们没有将快餐的扩张视为黑人资本主义的成功。但这正是其中的一部分。
Right. So black capitalism was a success in that it created more successful McDonald's franchises, and those places became de facto hubs for the black community. But it still failed, you know, in the broad sense for most African Americans, and that it didn't come close to making up for being shut out of political power or economic equality. So, let's go back in time when the promise of black capitalism was still a bit more propitious, and McDonald's was becoming intertwined with black communities. So, in Los Angeles in the 1970s, McDonald's had dozens of black franchise owners, including this man named Charles Griffiths. But they ended up in a lawsuit with Griffiths.
没错。所以黑人资本主义之所以成功，是因为它创造了更多成功的麦当劳特许经营店，这些地方成了黑人社区的事实枢纽。但对于大多数非裔美国人来说，它在广义上仍然失败了，因为它远未能弥补被排挤出政治权力或经济平等的损失。所以，让我们回到黑人资本主义的前景还更具希望、麦当劳正与黑人社区交织在一起的那个时代。因此，在20世纪70年代的洛杉矶，麦当劳拥有数十名黑人特许经营商，包括一个名叫查尔斯·格里菲斯的人。但他们最终与格里菲斯陷入了一场诉讼。
What happened there? Yeah, so it's so interesting to hear people talk about African-Americans in franchising because they use a lot of the language that people have come to understand around housing discrimination. So they talk about discrimination in lending, access to capital.
那里发生了什么？是的，听到人们谈论特许经营中的非裔美国人非常有意思，因为他们使用了许多人们在住房歧视周围已经理解的语言。所以他们谈论贷款歧视、获取资本的途径。
And then they talk about redlining, and they claim that McDonald's keeps two sets of lists of potential franchise locations that whites go to white neighborhoods and black people are confined to black neighborhoods. They talk about how if you are black and you move into a predominantly white territory, the white franchise owners come together to keep you out.
然后他们谈论红线歧视（划定居住区），他们声称麦当劳保留了两份潜在特许经营地点的名单，白人去白人社区，而黑人被限制在黑人社区。他们谈论如果你是黑人并且搬到一个主要是白人的地区，白人特许经营商会联合起来把你排挤出去。
And so these allegations are being made throughout the late 60s and 70s and 80s. And Charles Griffiths is this franchise owner who's so ready for prime time that the great tragedy of his story is that he didn't have Twitter in order for him to like try to get under McDonald's skin. And so in a nutshell, his wife tries to franchise of Popeyes. McDonald says that that is a breach that family members of a McDonald's franchise owner can't go into business with a competitor.
因此，这些指控在整个60年代、70年代和80年代一直都在被提出。查尔斯·格里菲斯就是这样一个特许经营商，他已经完全准备好大展身手了，他故事中的巨大悲剧在于他当时没有推特，好让他试着去让麦当劳难堪。简而言之，他的妻子试图加盟一家大力水手炸鸡（Popeyes）。麦当劳表示这是一种违约行为，麦当劳特许经营商的家庭成员不能与竞争对手做生意。
So he launches back and says, you know, actually, while you're at it, why can't we talk about this racial discrimination that I'm experiencing, that I'm not saying that I'm saying that I'm saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm not saying that I'm have given you. And Charles Griffiths is like always on time. He's like, you say you want me to be in my community. I'm a millionaire. I live in Belair. Why can't I be in that community as a business owner? And they go back and forth and it gets picked up by the New York Times. But I think at the heart of it is this question of what does an opportunity really look like or mean. And I think for African-Americans who had been shut out of the possibility of this business structure, there was an expectation from the corporate parent that they would just always be grateful.
于是他发起反击并说：“你知道，实际上，既然话说到这儿了，我们为什么不能谈谈我正在经历的这种种族歧视呢……我并不是说……我并不是说……我并不是说……”（注：此处口误重复省略）查尔斯·格里菲斯总是按时交钱。他就像是在说：“你们说希望我留在我的社区里。我是个百万富翁。我住在贝莱尔。为什么我不能作为一名企业主留在那个社区里呢？”他们争执不休，这事还被《纽约时报》报道了。但我认为这核心在于这样一个问题：机会到底是什么样子的，或者意味着什么。我想对于那些被排除在这种商业结构可能性之外的非裔美国人来说，母公司有一种期望，即他们应该永远心存感激。
And in this exchange, you also realize that by confining the places where African-Americans can do business, you just exacerbate some of the issues of inequality that people thought business ownership would actually fix. So this conflict boils up where they're in a little bit of a war with each other. So what did it up happening to Charles Griffiths? Well, Charles Griffiths, he gets the NAACP involved and the Los Angeles chapter actually initiates a selective boycott, which again is bananas because they have to invite people to boycott McDonald's, but not the black ones. You know which one of those are their dozen black neighborhoods, and that's the point of this boycott. McDonald's claims that they did not pay Griffith's assent for his ridiculous claims about racism.
而在这种交流中，你也会意识到，通过限制非裔美国人可以做生意的地点，你只会加剧一些不平等的问，而人们本以为拥有企业可以解决这些问题。因此，这场冲突爆发了，他们陷入了一场小规模的战争。那么查尔斯·格里菲斯最终结局如何？嗯，查尔斯·格里菲斯把全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）拉了进来，洛杉矶分部实际上发起了一场有选择性的抵制活动，这又一次太荒谬了，因为他们不得不邀请人们抵制麦当劳，但不能抵制黑人的那几家。你知道那些黑人社区里有十几家，这就是这场抵制的意义所在。麦当劳声称他们没有付给格里菲斯一分钱来回应他关于种族主义的可笑指控。
He gets bought out and he later reestablishes himself in a business called Chicken Charlie's, which he says he has gotten away from franchising, which is the White Man's game, and now he's doing something authentically black. The implication for this conflict, I think, is more interesting because the NAACP enters into negotiations with McDonald's, and this is a strategy they used throughout the 80s with corporations.
他被买断了股份，后来在一家名为“查理鸡”（Chicken Charlie's）的企业重新树立了自己，他说他已经摆脱了特许经营，那是“白人的游戏”，现在他正在做一些真正具有黑人特色的事情。我认为这场冲突的内涵更有趣，因为全国有色人种协进会开始与麦当劳进行谈判，这是他们在整个80年代对各大企业采取的一种策略。
That there's a claim of racism. There's some type of selective buying campaign or boycott, and then they come to the table and it includes charitable donations, it includes sponsoring NAACP programs. 15-area students just weeks away from heading off to college were awarded scholarships earlier tonight thanks in part to a partnership between the NAACP and McDonald's. This marks the 10th year that two have partnered to provide Jefferson County students with opportunities for high- And then it opens up more white-collar jobs to African Americans.
首先是关于种族主义的指控。然后是一些有选择性的购买运动或抵制活动，接着他们坐到谈判桌前，其中包括慈善捐款，包括赞助全国有色人种协进会的项目。就在几分钟前，由于全国有色人种协进会和麦当劳之间的合作，15名离上大学只有几周时间的地区学生获得了奖学金。这标志着双方合作十周年，为杰斐逊县的学生提供高级发展机会——然后它向非裔美国人开放了更多白领工作。
So it never really settles the issue of red lighting and it never really goes deep into that. But it creates this context that the remedy for racial inequality is opportunity. And essentially we're living that moment over and over again today. So McDonald's was doing this work behind the scenes with franchisees, but it also was doing these massive ad campaigns aimed at African Americans.
所以它从未真正解决红线划定的问题，也从未真正深入探讨过这一点。但它创造了这样一种背景，即种族不平等的救济就是机会。从本质上讲，我们今天还在一遍又一遍地经历那个时刻。所以麦当劳一直在幕后与特许经营商进行这项工作，但它同时也针对非裔美国人开展了大规模的广告活动。
So how did McDonald's try to appeal to black customers? So the idea that a big company markets to African Americans is a pretty old concept that really took shape around the Great Migration, where you have a mass migration of black people from the south who are moving to northern cities and have more commercial choices. But things take a more ridiculous turn, if you will, in the 1960s, where these market research firms, some black owned, are trying to do really tailored marketing to African-Americans. So they're not just coloring the faces of models to make them black or putting African-American
那么麦当劳是如何试图吸引黑人顾客的呢？所以，大公司向非裔美国人进行营销的想法是一个相当古老的概念，它真正成形于大迁徙时期，当时黑人从南方大批迁移到北部城市，拥有了更多的商业选择。但如果你愿意的话，事情在20世纪60年代朝着更荒谬的方向发展，这些市场研究公司，有些是黑人拥有的，正试图针对非裔美国人进行真正量身定制的营销。所以他们不只是给模特的脸涂黑以使其看起来像黑人，或者把非裔美国人
models in the same types of print ads that white models would be in. They are trying to speak directly to that consumer market. And so in the 1960s, African-American franchise owners convinced McDonald's to retain the services of brawl communications, which is one of the most important African-American advertising firms of the period and up to today. And so we're gonna get the triple down, my best friend will be. And next time on the, yeah. We knew it all for you.
模特放在白人模特会上的那种平面广告中。他们试图直接与那个消费市场对话。所以在20世纪60年代，非裔美国人特许经营商说服麦当劳保留了布罗尔传播公司（Bral Communications）的服务，这是那个时期乃至今天最最重要的非裔美国人广告公司之一。所以我们将迎来三重暴击，我最好的朋友将会是……下一次在……是的。我们所做的一切都是为了你。
You know, these ads are very of their time. There are afros, there are dashikis. There's, you know, dropped G's. There's a lot of being cool. It is painful to look at in hindsight, but I do think that there is value to what this kind of marketing is animating for black consumers. So McDonald's used to run these ads, starring a character named Calvin. And in the ads, Calvin is this young black man who gets a job at McDonald's and basically
你知道，这些广告非常具有那个时代的特征。有爆炸头，有非洲长袍。你知道，有省略掉词尾G的发音。有很多关于耍酷的元素。事后回看，这让人感到痛苦，但我确实认为，这种营销对黑人消费者所激发的东西是有价值的。所以麦当劳过去常播这些广告，由一个叫卡尔文的角色主演。在广告中，卡尔文是一个年轻的黑人男子，他在麦当劳找到了一份工作，并且基本上
turns his life around to him. These were everywhere on TV. Let's listen to one. There is something different about him. It just goes the show. You can't judge a book by its cover. It looks like responsibility has been good for him. One the way he's working. Welcome to the Donald's, man. I hope you... Wow, Calvin.
扭转了他的生活。这些广告在电视上随处可见。让我们听听其中一个。他身上有些东西不一样了。这正好说明了。人不可貌相。看起来责任感对他的改变很大。看看他工作的样子。欢迎来到麦当劳，老兄。我希望你……哇，卡尔文。
Yeah. Calvin, indeed. That's almost like a short film devoted to black capitalism. It has many parts, too. Yeah, it keeps developing. I mean, like he's a young teen in this incarnation and then he gets older and then he gets fancy clothes later on. It's the newest member of our management team.
是的。卡尔文，确实如此。这简直就像是一部专门献给黑人资本主义的短片。它也有很多部分。是的，它一直在发展。我的意思是，在这个版本中他还是个十几岁的少年，然后他变老了，后来他穿上了华丽的衣服。我们管理团队最新的一员。
Calvin. Congratulations. I'm a really healthy. Cool. You have a fun fun management team now, mama. Oh, baby, I'm so proud of you. The kids must the stupid part, Invious of the money he earns.
卡尔文。祝贺你。我真的非常健康。酷。你现在有一个有趣的、有趣的管理团队了，妈妈。哦，宝贝，我为你感到骄傲。孩子们一定……愚蠢的部分，嫉妒他赚的钱。
So talk to me about Calvin and what you think of when you see these ads. So Calvin is a creation of some market research about a concern that fast food jobs are no longer cool. And so the Calvin campaign was to make, working at McDonald's something that teens wanted to do, but it's also a call back to some of the representations of African-American teenagers that were negative.
所以跟我聊聊卡尔文，以及当你看到这些广告时你的想法。所以卡尔文是根据一项市场研究创造出来的，该研究发现快餐工作不再那么酷了。因此卡尔文广告旨在让在麦当劳工作成为青少年想做的事情，但它也是对以往对非裔美国青少年的某些负面形象的一种反思。
Because part of the conceit of the Calvin ad is you think he's like a bad kid from the street, but McDonald's gives him so much discipline because they give him a job, and he becomes a fixture in his community. And this kind of ad, I think, straddles this transition from the ads in the late 60s and 70s, we're working class people.
因为卡尔文广告的构思部分在于，你以为他是个街头坏小孩，但麦当劳给了他如此多的纪律，因为他们给了他一份工作，而他成为了他社区里的一个固定成员。而这种广告，我认为，跨越了从60年代末和70年代的广告的过渡，当时我们是工人阶级。
It was about being cool, it was hanging out, and then a transition into the 80s, which is what I call the Cosby term, more middle class families and a little bit more aspirational in its tone. And then in the late 80s and early 90s, using the tropes of kind of rap culture or the street culture to promote McDonald's. And that's the introduction of rap music.
重点在于耍酷、闲逛，然后过渡到80年代，也就是我所说的“考斯比时代”，更多的是中产阶级家庭，基调也更加雄心勃勃。然后在80年代末和90年代初，利用说唱文化或街头文化的隐喻来推广麦当劳。这就是说唱音乐的引入。
The thing I find hilarious about this is that Calvin is in a block in Harlem, and the stoop his friends hang out on is now $10 million and has been in house beautiful. But at the time, it was supposed to indicate working class communities. And it's this idea that McDonald's isn't just a presence in your community in that it provides cheap food fast, but it has this effect on young people,
我觉得这最搞笑的地方在于，卡尔文在哈林区的一个街区，他朋友们闲逛的那个门廊台阶现在价值1000万美元，还登上过《绝美家居》（House Beautiful）。但在当时，它本意是指工人阶级社区。而且这种想法是，麦当劳不仅以提供廉价快餐的方式存在于你的社区中，它对年轻人还有这种影响，
young people that you would otherwise be afraid of, and McDonald's can kind of soothe your anxieties about them. I do want to not judge it too harshly in today's mores and sort of treat it as it was, but there's a line that's just like, he isn't what you'd think. You know, it's like kind of stated, and you're like, I don't think anything.
那些你原本会感到害怕的年轻人，而麦当劳可以某种程度上平息你对他们的焦虑。我确实不想用今天的道德标准去过分苛求它，而是把它当作它本来的样子来看待，但里面有一句台词就像是，“他和你想象的不一样。”你知道，这就有点像是说出来了，然后你会觉得，我什么都没想啊。
I've seen him for 10 seconds. Yeah, it's like kind of stated and you're like, I don't think anything. I've seen him for 10 seconds. Yeah, it's like, well, who's the, who's the what? Who's the you? You know, like these words are doing quite a bit, but also it was this idea that fast food jobs are not dead end jobs. And I think that criticism that emerges during that period
我才看了他10秒钟。是的，就像是有点说出来了，然后你会觉得，我什么都没想啊。我才看了他10秒钟。是的，这就好比，到底谁是那个……谁是那个“你”？你知道，这些词起了相当大的作用，但这也是一种理念，即快餐工作并不是死胡同的工作。而且我认为那个时期出现的批评
is also being addressed here. I mean, so many things are happening in these ads, but they're also saying it's a cool place to work, it's a good place to work, it's not Jed and that for African Americans it can leverage them. And in one of the final ads, you know, he starts, you know, using about one day becoming a franchise owner. It's like Calvin has done the full capitalism loop. For real? Calvin? Calvin, they used to hang out on the corner? So you own McDonald's. No, not shit. So in addition to add speaking to the values of being
也在这里得到了回应。我的意思是，这些广告中发生了太多的事情，但它们也在说这是一个很酷的工作地方，是一个好工作地方，它不是死胡同，而且对于非裔美国人来说，它可以成为他们的跳板。在其中一个最后的广告中，你知道，他开始，你知道，谈论有一天成为一名特许经营商。这就好像卡尔文已经完成了完整的资本主义闭环。真的吗？卡尔文？卡尔文，那个以前总在街角闲逛的人？所以你拥有一家麦当劳？不，还没呢。所以除了宣传融入
part of the McDonald's family, there was also the incorporation of black culture into McDonald's ads, which brings us to the double Dutch ad. Let's be backly at fish quarter pound and french fries to McDonald's and that's which brings us to the double Dutch ad. It's this really kind of lovely modest neighborhood. Everyone has a well-kemped front yard and a group of people related, maybe fictive kin, are watching these roles do double Dutch and they're just so good in terms of the athleticism and then they're just having so much fun. And I remember ads like that being really distinctive in that they're showing African-American culture that was like visible to me.
麦当劳大家庭价值观的广告外，还有将黑人文化融入麦当劳广告的做法，这就把我们带到了双荷兰跳绳（Double Dutch）广告。让我们回到麦当劳的鱼排巨无霸四分之一磅汉堡和薯条，这就把我们带到了双荷兰跳绳广告。这是一个非常可爱朴素的社区。每个人都有一个打理得很好的前院，一群亲戚（可能是虚构的亲属）正在看着这些女孩跳双荷兰跳绳，她们在运动能力方面表现得太棒了，而且她们玩得那么开心。我记得这样的广告非常独特，因为它们展示了非裔美国人的文化，这对我来说是清晰可见的。
Like this could be my sister and her older friends like doing double Dutch, not as artfully, but doing double Dutch nonetheless. And those commercials were not only, you know, like a marketing strategy. They were also part of McDonald's underwriting a double dutch lead that would travel around the country that had its origins and keeping kids off the street and out of trouble. And in watching so many of these ads, I started to really think about not only the politics of representation and what it means for African Americans to see themselves on television after having long histories of exclusion from the marketplace,
就像这可能是我姐姐和她较大的朋友们在玩双荷兰跳绳一样，虽然没有那么充满艺术感，但依然在玩双荷兰跳绳。这些商业广告不仅是一个营销策略。它们也是麦当劳赞助全国巡回双荷兰跳绳联赛的一部分，该联赛起源于让孩子们远离街头和麻烦。在观看了这么多这样的广告之后，我开始真正思考的不仅是代表权的政治，以及非裔美国人在经历长期的市场排斥后在电视上看到自己意味着什么，
but just a number of people who were like paid, the number of black creatives who were able to get jobs as a result of these huge marketing shifts, I think it's important to acknowledge that, even as I'm so critical and awful about the whole thing. Even though I'm the worst. It's just a kill-droid. whole thing. I think it's easy to dismiss this outreach in terms of marketing the black community as a crash and commercial. But McDonald's also was involved in establishing MLK's
还有就是有多少人拿到了报酬，有多少黑人创意人员因为这些巨大的营销转变而能够获得工作，我认为承认这一点很重要，尽管我对整件事情持如此批判和糟糕的态度。尽管我是最糟糕的。这只是一个……整个事情。我认为很容易将这种针对黑人社区的营销外展活动视为粗俗和商业化的。但麦当劳也参与了将马丁·路德·金的
birthday as a holiday. McDonald's joins the nation in celebrating the legacy of Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. Well, they were very early among the corporations that said MLK is something that we want to do because before Martin Luther King became this like warm fuzzy that people love. That was a process. And the first step in it was legitimating and essentially rootonizing the MLK holiday. So after its past in 83, a lot of people are kind of not sure if this is something they want to get behind. There was a lot of conversation in Congress if Frederick Douglass should have a holiday because he was a more honorable American. And so the process of keeping the MLK holiday as a space in which to celebrate African Americans, it needed help. And McDonald's African American franchise owners really led the way in creating King
生日确立为法定节假日。麦当劳与全国人民一同庆祝马丁·路德·金博士的传奇。嗯，在那些表示“马丁·路德·金是我们想要纪念的事物”的企业中，他们是非常早期的参与者，因为在马丁·路德·金变成如今这样一个备受人们喜爱的温暖模糊形象之前。那是一个过程。而其中的第一步是使马丁·路德·金假日合法化，并在本质上使其常规化。所以在83年通过后，很多人其实并不确定这是否是他们想要支持的事情。国会中有很多关于弗雷德里克·道格拉斯是否应该拥有一个假日的讨论，因为他是一个更受尊敬的美国人。因此，将马丁·路德·金假日作为一个庆祝非裔美国人的空间的进程，需要帮助。而麦当劳的非裔美国人特许经营商在创造金的
ephemera of underwriting some of the big parades and the celebrations. And corporate was behind it because I think that they had grafted so much of their entry into Black America onto the event of King's assassination and they were able to really parlay the King holiday into something accessible to a large audience. And so I think that that kind of cultural work
相关纪念品、赞助一些大型游行和庆祝活动方面确实起到了带头作用。而总公司也支持这一做法，因为我认为他们已经将他们进入黑人美国的很大一部分根基建立在了金遇刺这一事件之上，并且他们确实能够将金假日转化为大众容易接受的东西。所以我觉得那种文化工作
is again something that is so important to us because the way that the king holiday has been so sanitized and depoliticized, it's hard to imagine a world in which a corporation sponsoring it would actually be a risky move. So let's move forward to the 1990s. So after the uprising following the beating of Rodney King in 1992, the CEO of McDonald said that the restaurants in Los Angeles had been spared from looting and property damage. And he said this was because of how McDonald's adopted its quote, enlightened social policies more than three decades ago. And quote, so does that bring true to you?
对我们来说同样非常重要，因为鉴于金假日被如此消毒和去政治化，很难想象这样一个世界：一家企业赞助它实际上会是一个冒险的举动。那么让我们快进到20世纪90年代。所以在1992年罗德尼·金被殴打引发起义之后，麦当劳首席执行官表示，洛杉矶的餐厅免于遭到打砸抢烧和财产损失。他说这是因为麦当劳在三十多年前采用了所谓的“开明社会政策”。那么，这听起来对你来说是真的吗？
It's such a weird thing to say. This was one of the early pieces of research that I found in working on this project, and I was obsessed with this idea. The claim is so outrageous to me, and so wildly inappropriate, that I went to the archives of the University of Southern California that had all of the kind of commission reports about the uprising to try to disprove it. There's a lot of speculative stuff that I can get into, but the point is that some McDonald's were targeted and one McDonald's was a staging area for the National Guard.
这话听起来太奇怪了。这是我在做这个项目时发现的早期研究资料之一，我当时对这个想法着迷不已。这种说法对我来说太离谱了，也极其不合适，以至于我去了南加州大学的档案馆，那里保存了所有关于那场起义的委员会报告，试图去反驳它。有很多推测性的东西我可以展开讲，但重点是某些麦当劳确实成为了目标，还有一家麦当劳是国民警卫队的集结地。
And what I realized is it didn't actually matter if this was true. It was the fact that McDonald's had positioned itself after 68 up into 1992 as being a member of Black America that people believed it and they celebrated it. I have heard this story from Black franchise owners, I've heard this from business professors, it is in, you know, those case studies about corporate social responsibility. This narrative is so powerful. corporate social responsibility. This narrative is so powerful. During the recent protests, McDonald's certainly hasn't been hailed as a civil rights champion. Actually, one of the McDonald's here in Oakland, there's been a strike
而我意识到的是，这是否属实其实并不重要。关键在于麦当劳把自己定位为从68年一直到1992年黑人美国的一员，以至于人们相信了这一点并且为此庆祝。我从黑人特许经营商那里听说过这个故事，从商业教授那里听说过，它甚至存在于那些关于企业社会责任的案例研究中。这个叙事是如此强大。企业社会责任。这个叙事是如此强大。在最近的抗议活动中，麦当劳当然没有被誉为民权斗士。事实上，奥克兰这里的其中一家麦当劳，一直有一场
going on over the safety conditions during the pandemic. So a few days ago, McDonald's had the audacity to put out a statement saying, you're one of us. McDonald's brilliant dollar business is clueless that the brown and black people that it hires, it does not respect the basic rights. Our producer Emmett Fitzgerald went down to a protest outside that McDonald's and he talked with one of the employees Sandra Romano who was picketing there. Here she is being translated.
罢工在进行，起因是疫情期间的安全状况。所以几天前，麦当劳竟然厚颜无耻地发表了一份声明，说：“你们是我们的自己人。”麦当劳这个价值十亿美元的企业根本不明白，它雇佣的棕色和黑色人种，它却不尊重其基本权利。我们的制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）去到那家麦当劳外面的抗议现场，采访了在那里设立纠察线的员工桑德拉·罗马诺（Sandra Romano）。这是对她的采访翻译。
When the health department mandated to provide masks, we got masks but they were doggy diapers. We have to wear them also for a few days until they break down. Also, the gloves that they provided to us, they wear not a special gloves, for example, for the caciers. We were wearing the gloves that they use in the kitchen and they are really, really light gloves that they didn't provide any protection to us.
当卫生部门强制要求提供口罩时，我们拿到了口罩，但它们是狗狗尿布。我们还得连续几天戴着它们，直到它们破损。此外，他们发给我们的手套也不是特制手套，比如给收银员用的。我们戴的是他们在厨房里用的手套，那是真的很薄很薄的手套，根本无法为我们提供任何保护。
So this is a McDonald's owned by a black franchisee and many of those striking workers at this McDonald's are people of color. So what does this tell you about where we are with black capitalism today? I guess the way we got here is that there is a notion that any opportunity is a good opportunity for black America that crumbs can sustain people who are hungry. And I think what has happened is that the fast food industry can continue to thrive in
所以这是一 家由黑人特许经营商拥有的麦当劳，这家麦当劳的许多罢工工人都是有色人种。那么这向你说明了我们今天黑人资本主义的现状如何？我想我们走到这一步的原因是有一种观念，即任何机会对黑人美国来说都是好机会，面包屑可以维持饥饿之人的生命。而我认为发生的事情是，快餐行业可以继续依靠
not providing people, you know, a safe and sound work environment, what we are confronted with right now is this distance between saying that a corporation supports black lives and then the treatment of black workers. You have the distance of celebrating the frontline worker and then not being concerned when the frontline worker gets sick. I think that I can see why franchise owners are so vulnerable to a number of these things, but I think that this is always a good time to take a step back and say, is this really the path toward freedom? When we fight, when we fight, exactly, and that's why we're here in support of the McDonald's workers who are striking. I think that how well a merchandiser does or how many
不为人们提供安全健全的工作环境而蓬勃发展，我们现在面对的是这样一种距离：一方面声称企业支持黑人生命，另一方面却如此对待黑人工人。你既庆祝一线工人，又在一线工人生病时漠不关心。我想我能理解为什么特许经营商对其中许多事情如此脆弱，但我认为这总是一个退后一步、扪心自问的好时机：“这真的是通往自由的道路吗？”当我们抗争，当我们抗争，没错，这就是为什么我们在这里支持罢工的麦当劳工人。我认为一个商家做得有多好或者卖出了多少
burgers sold should not have a material impact on whether people live or die. This is the place that I think I find myself in that I actually don't care if McDonald's makes hamburgers and I actually don't care if McDonald's makes hamburgers. And I actually don't care if people eat them and whether you think they're eating too many of them. I do care if McDonald's is able to set a policy agenda that says we can pay workers this and everyone else is gonna pay workers this. And this is how much suppliers can make
汉堡，不应该对人们的生死产生实质性影响。这就是我发现自己所处的心境：我其实并不在乎麦当劳是否制作汉堡，我其实并不在乎麦当劳是否制作汉堡。我甚至不在乎人们是否吃它们，以及你是否认为他们吃得太多。我在乎的是麦当劳是否能够制定这样一项政策议程：我们可以付给工人这个工资，然后其他所有人也都将付给工人这个工资。这就是供应商可以赚取的利润，
and this is how we're gonna set the market to the detriment of people. When you pass McDonald's today, what do you see? What do you want people to notice? Every time I pass McDonald's or any fast food, I can usually tell what year it was built. You know, the two things that have emerged from it, one, the fun part is I've appreciated the creative energy of the fast food industry. I knew that prior to doing this work, I knew that it was a lot of work to work in fast food, but I think the skill involved in delivering so much food so quickly, hot, is still something
以及我们将如何以损害人们利益为代价来设定市场。当你今天走过麦当劳时，你看到了什么？你希望人们注意到什么？每次我经过麦当劳或任何快餐店，我通常都能看出它是哪一年建造的。你知道，从中衍生出的两件事，第一件，有趣的部分是我开始欣赏快餐行业的创造力。在做这项工作之前我知道，我知道在快餐店工作需要付出很多努力，但我认为如此迅速地交付如此大量的热腾腾食物所涉及的技巧，依然是
that is so amazing to me and that is so degraded, but the efficiency of it and the skill required to do it, I've become more appreciative of. And then what I also see is a place of deep meaning, even as I think it sometimes can undermine value. And so I think I've come to a place of understanding that fast food can be harmful, and it can be deeply meaningful. And that is the space in which I think our best struggle comes out of.
让我如此惊叹的事，尽管它经常被贬低，但我对它的效率以及完成它所需的技能变得更加赞赏了。然后我看到的也是一个充满深意的地方，尽管我认为它有时会削弱价值。所以我认为我达到了这样一种理解：快餐既可能是有害的，也可能是意义深远的。而正是在这个空间里，我认为我们最好的斗争才会涌现出来。
Thank you so much for talking with us. I really enjoyed our conversation. I really appreciate it. Oh my gosh, this is so fun. Martian Chaplin's book is called Franchise. The Golden Arch is in Black America. There is so much more to the story than what we can cover here, so you really need to read it. We'll have a link on the website.
非常感谢你与我们交谈。我真的很享受我们的对话。我非常感激。哦天哪，这太有趣了。玛莎·查特林的这本书叫《特许经营：黑人美国与金色拱门》。这个故事的内容远比我们在这里讨论的要多得多，所以你真的需要去读一读。我们会在网站上提供链接。
Black capitalism is often presented as a solution to African American political and economic inequality, even though it's proven to be completely inadequate. But another concept that has been talked about but has never even been tried is reparations. This is the idea of attempting to make amends for slavery and the economic inequality that followed by providing some form of financial compensation. We have a story about one person's attempt at DIY reparations from the radio show The Heart that you do not want to miss. On the radio topia podcast The Heart, they ran a special mini-series by Phoebe Ounter,
黑人资本主义经常被视为解决非裔美国人政治和经济不平等问题的方案，尽管事实证明它完全是杯水车薪。但另一个被谈论过却从未真正尝试过的概念是赔偿。这个概念是通过提供某种形式的财务补偿，来试图为奴隶制以及随之而来的经济不平等进行弥补。我们有一个来自广播节目《心脏》（The Heart）的故事，讲述了一个人尝试自己动手进行赔偿的经历，你绝对不想错过。在Radiotopia的播客节目《心脏》上，他们播出了菲比·翁特（Phoebe Unter）制作的一个特别迷你系列，
called Race Trader, where she examines her own white privilege and explores ways to this ruptured. And in the third episode, she considers the all-white neighborhood she grew up in, and comes to the conclusion that her parents should give away their home to serve as reparations for benefiting from racist housing covenants. This excerpt starts with Phoebe talking about the moment a couple decades ago when her parents set up a new life for their new family. And then my parents' decisions focus on us. They move us across the state line from Missouri to Kansas for better schools. We move into a big beautiful house in a neighborhood called Mission Hills.
名为《种族交易员》，她在其中审视了自己的白人特权，并探索了弥合这种裂痕的方法。在第三集中，她谈到了自己长大的全白人社区，得出的结论是，她的父母应该把他们的房子捐出去，作为对受益于种族主义住房契约的赔偿。这个节选开始于菲比讲述几十年前她的父母为新家庭开启新生活的那一刻。然后，我父母的决定都是为了我们。他们带着我们跨越州界，从密苏里州搬到堪萨斯州，为了更好的学校。我们搬进了一个名为米森希尔斯的社区里一栋宏伟漂亮的房子。
I become aware of the man who built this neighborhood early in my childhood. His name is J.C. Nichols. It's on street signs in Kansas City and there's a big public fountain named after him. I grew up thinking he was wonderful and important and cared about beauty and long-lasting quality architecture. I am told that when the house we live in was built, black people and Jews could not have lived in it. And I'm told that's just how it was then. It's no longer enforceable.
在我童年早期，我就意识到了这个社区的建造者。他的名字叫J·C·尼科尔斯。堪萨斯城的路标上有他的名字，还有一个以他名字命名的大型公共喷泉。我从小就认为他是一个伟大、重要的人，并且关心美感和持久的高质量建筑。我被告知，当我们住的房子建造时，黑人和犹太人是不能住在里面的。而且我被告知当时情况就是这样。现在这已经不再具备法律效力了。
Then five years ago, I'm reading this book. It's actually a book my mom sent me in the mail, written by Tanner Colby. And there's a chapter about JC Nichols. And for the first time, I read these words. JC Nichols died in 1950, but his plan for permanence lives on. His racial covenants are still with us, auto renewing year after year, like some horrible gym membership will never get out of. And for the first time, I read about how J.C. Nichols is known for perfecting the all white neighborhood by
然后五年前，我正在读这本书。这实际上是我妈妈寄给我的书，由坦纳·科尔比所著。里面有一章是关于J·C·尼科尔斯的。我生平第一次读到了这些字句：J·C·尼科尔斯于1950年去世，但他对永恒的规划依然延续。他的种族契约依然伴随着我们，年复一年自动续签，就像某个永远无法退订的糟糕健身房会员卡一样。我生平第一次读到J·C·尼科尔斯是如何以完善全白人社区而闻名的
using racial covenants, meaning that the property deeds for all the houses in his neighborhoods included this line. None of S.D.L.A.D. may be conveyed to, used, owned or occupied by Negroes as owners or tenants. His racial covenants became all the rage. Developers all over the country mimicked neighborhoods like Mission Hills. JC Nichols became so influential that coming out of the Great Depression, when the federal government was deciding who should get low-interest mortgages to stimulate home buying and building. They brought JC Nichols into the Oval Office to advise. And they copied whole sections of his company handbook
通过使用种族条款，这意味着他社区里所有房子的房产契约都包含这样一行字：土地或其任何部分不得转让、使用、拥有或由黑人作为业主或租客占据。他的种族条款风靡一时。全国各地的开发商都在模仿米森希尔斯这样的社区。J·C·尼科尔斯变得如此具有影响力，以至于大萧条过后，当联邦政府决定谁应该获得低息抵押贷款以刺激购房和建筑时，他们把J·C·尼科尔斯请进了椭圆形办公室担任顾问。他们把他公司手册中的整整几个章节
right into their brand new policies. The policies that became known as redlining and redlining influenced the value of housing for decades into the 50s when returning war war two vets were looking to buy property. That's when suburbs took off. And then I read this, the suburban land grab of the 20th century
直接复制到了他们崭新的政策中。这些政策后来被称为红线划定，而红线划定影响了长达几十年的住房价值，直到50年代二战退伍军人寻找房产时也是如此。也就是在那时，郊区蓬勃发展。然后我读到了这个：20世纪的郊区土地争夺战
was one of the single greatest engines of wealth creation in human history. It took a country of second and third generation white ethnic immigrants, vaulted them into the middle class and sent all their kids to college. I know I was naive. Shouldn't everyone assume what they have
是人类历史上创造财富的最伟大的引擎之一。它把一个由第二代和第三代白人欧洲移民组成的国家推向中产阶级，并把他们所有的孩子送上了大学。我知道我当时很天真。难道每个人不都应该认为他们所拥有的
comes at the expense of other people? We live in America. This is its foundation. But it's one thing to know this generally, and another to see the specific ways what I have came at the expense of others. For my parents though, it's not that big of a deal. My family needs to reckon with what we're harboring, what we've inherited, and are maintaining as an intergenerational wealth management system.
是以牺牲其他人为代价的吗？我们生活在美利坚。这就是它的基石。但普遍地知道这一点是一回事，而亲眼看到我所拥有的一切是如何以牺牲他人为代价的具体方式则是另一回事。然而对于我的父母来说，这并不是什么大不了的事。我的家庭需要正视我们所庇护、继承并作为代际财富管理系统维护的东西。
A.K.A. A White Family. I want to help my parents let go of this idea of themselves as innocent and disconnected from JC Nichols' legacy, because we're not innocent living on land that first of all is stolen from indigenous people and then made into neighborhoods where people of color were kept out. Stripping those families of the chance to buy property to pass on to their children like my parents plan to pass on their house to me. We are not innocent owning a home that continues to appreciate and value on this land. Here are Phoebe's parents, Ellen and Steve. But it doesn't help you. I didn't change anything I did related to the show.
也就是：一个白人家庭。我想帮我的父母抛弃这种认为自己是无辜的、与J·C·尼科尔斯的遗产无关的想法，因为我们并不无辜，我们生活在这样一片土地上：首先是从原住民那里偷来的，然后被改造成将有色人种排除在外的社区。剥夺了这些家庭购买房产并传给他们孩子的机会，正如我父母计划把他们的房子传给我一样。我们拥有在这片土地上不断增值的住宅，这并不无辜。这里是菲比的父母，埃伦和史蒂夫。但这并没有帮到你。我并没有改变任何与这个节目有关的做法。
Well, that's what I'm saying. But it still made you feel... Oh, okay. Well, I come across... Made you feel what? Well, I'm probably using the icky isn't the right word, but it just, I thought it was bad. You know, I mean, because I like to sit in this house sometimes
好吧，这就是我想说的。但这还是让你觉得……哦，好吧。嗯，我偶然发现……让你觉得什么？嗯，我可能用的词不太对，但它只是，我觉得这不好。你知道，我的意思是，因为我有时喜欢坐在这个房子里
and, you know, wonder, will... Okay, like in the 30s, people were living here and our house pretty much looks most of it looks exactly the same as it did. And we know that a Democrat on our house and so they were probably like Roosevelt supporters and he was written up in the Democrat repeat. But you know that when they signed the paperwork, they knew it was in those governor. How do you know? Because it was part of the current bill. Do I have to advertise it? Mom, I looked at advertisements for Mission Hill as it say. What did you do?
然后，你知道，纳闷，会……好吧，就像在30年代，人们曾住在这里，我们的房子几乎大部分看起来和以前完全一样。我们知道我们房子的民主党人，所以他们可能像罗斯福的支持者，他被写在民主党重印版里。但你知道当他们签署文件时，他们知道里面有那个条款。你怎么知道？因为那是条款的一部分。我非得去宣扬它吗？妈，我看了米森希尔斯的广告，上面写着。你做了什么？
It's in the f***ing book. Is it no black people? No, it says live in a neighborhood with the most desirable associations, which at the time is very obviously racially coded language to say other high society white people. I mean, I do have to say it sounds like you're in denial. No, I'm not. I'm not in denial. Both of you, the fact that you want to dispute the facts rather than just... No.
它就在那该死的书里。上面没有黑人吗？不，上面说的是住在拥有最令人向往的社群的社区，当时这显然是经过种族编码的语言，意思是其他上流社会的白人。我的意思是，我不得不说，听起来你们是在否认。不，我没有。我没有在否认。你们两个，你们想要争论事实而不是……不。
I'm not getting through to my parents. I feel like I need a different approach. I need to different approach. I need to have this basic conversation with my parents about how their choices affect other people that aren't us. They make choices, other white parents make choices, and it doesn't really matter if their motives are all the same, but these choices become part of larger patterns. And excerpt from Episode 3 of Race Trader, from The Heart by Phoebe Hunter.
我无法与我的父母沟通。我觉得我需要一种不同的方法。我需要一种不同的方法。我需要与我的父母进行这种基础的对话，谈谈他们的选择是如何影响到并非我们这样的其他人的。他们做出选择，其他白人父母也做出选择，他们的动机是否完全相同其实并不重要，但这些选择成为了更大模式的一部分。选自菲比·亨特制作的《心灵》播客中《种族交易员》第三集。
The full episode and series is intense and fascinating and will really make you think, it'll definitely challenge you. And it might even make some of you angry, but I was riveted the whole time. You should listen. Find it at theheartpodcast.org. 99% of visual was produced this week by Chris Barube, music by Sean Royale. Kurt Colstead is the digital director of the rest of the team.
完整的一集和整个系列都非常紧张且迷人，真的会引发你的思考，绝对会挑战你的观念。甚至可能会让你们中的一些人气愤，但我全程都被深深吸引了。你们应该去听听。请在theheartpodcast.org上找到它。本周的“99%无形”由克里斯·巴鲁比制作，音乐由肖恩·罗亚尔创作。库特·科尔斯特德是制作团队的数字总监。
Is senior editor Delaney Hall, Katie Mangle, Sheree Fusif, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Abby Madonna, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is now distributed in multiple locations throughout North America, but in our heart will always be. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener supported 100% artist-owned podcast in the world. Find us all at radiotopia.fm.
高级编辑是德兰妮·霍尔、凯蒂·曼格、谢里·福西夫、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·勒、乔·罗森伯格、艾比·麦当娜、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 K-A-L-W电台的一个项目，制作于广播街，现在分发到北美洲的多个地点，但我们的心将永远在美丽、充满活力的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下电台乌托邦的自豪成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、由听众支持、100%由艺术家拥有的播客组成的激烈独立的集体。请在radiotopia.fm上找到我们。
You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI, or go on Instagram and read it too. But we have links to franchising, the hard and all kinds of other things that we talked about on this episode at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. From P-R-X. Utopia. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上@罗曼·马尔斯和节目@99PI，也可以去Instagram上关注并阅读。我们在99PI.org上提供了关于特许经营、心脏播客以及我们在本节目中讨论的各种其他事物的链接。来自PRX的电台乌托邦。来自PRX的乌托邦。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。